businessman
Anthony kirari knows his local suppliers
he often comes to pick up the old
newspapers this time there's nearly 350
kilograms
he pays about 63 euros for the whole his
Factory is in Judah about 30 kilometres
outside the Kenyan capital Nairobi
Anthony founded his company green
pencils on his family's land along with
an old friend Ivan or Cheng they're
ecologically friendly pencil business is
the job creator and doesn't require more
trees to be cut down most conventional
pencils are made from the wood of old
sitters or the restaurant of offensive
and in two three weeks at most a month
so your cattle are too that can last for
2,000 years to make our gadgets it took
the true and electrical engineer about
five years to develop the right formula
for a recycled paper pencil Anthony came
up with a concept when he worked as a
waste collector and the factory cut up
sheets of newspaper glued around
graphite sticks then a machine Rose them
up tightly creating the basic unadorned
pencil the exact technique for finishing
the newspaper pencil is a company secret
only the factory manager and her bosses
know it the partners themselves come to
the factory each week to do the
finishing work
Anthony's partner Ivanov Chang is in
charge of marketing and legal issues
there's a lot of disregard for
intellectual property in Africa is
personal and in some parts of Asia so we
have to gather our secret because if we
don't tomorrow somebody else will do the
same thing and another and another and
another over the last five years orders
have been continually increasing last
year the company's sales amounted to
around 130,000 euros schools and
companies are the biggest customers
during peak season the company employs
50 people to produce half a million
pencils in the quieter months there are
eight workers still there's more
potential in Kenya for eco-friendly
pencils the figures as a standard slowly
about a hundred and fifty million pesos
I imported into the country so you can
imagine if we only obtained 30 percent
of that market
there's enough for everyone right here
Kenya's government agencies import about
10 million pencils each year
Anthony Curie hopes to convince the
government to consider using their
recycled products I want to get into
politics today as the MP for Julia and I
pray that I make it and once I make it
my main task will be albe basically a
green warrior to go and fight for the
green space within governments such that
Kenya can be one of the role models for
the region within the East Africa region
and maybe even Africa concern for the
environment is something the true
entrepreneurs share Ivan runs
other businesses too but he says Green
pencils is closest to his heart this is
the only planet that I know I can
surviving so my small contribution is
good enough because the worst perception
is everybody sits back and imagine or
somebody else is going to serve this
this planet it's you and me heading back
to Nairobi the business partner
Stoppard's am Kappo a successful Kenyan
sort of to personally make the first an
degree there
from now on the solar energy company
will be enhancing its green crabs with
green pencils